[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm here because i'm
against the
safe ticket
because it's not safe i work with the
elderly people and um they say oh i'm
gonna go to that event because it's safe
because hey there's a coffee safe ticket
and then they are sick the next week
they are sick
from kovitz so it's it's um it's like
throwing the
uh
yeah
the the
people with uh
risks
for the lions it's it's not it's not
safe it's not a good measure against
kovit to say the truth
and not to mislead the people
and take care of the vulnerable
but leave the other people healthy
people go to work go to school
go to party etcetera
[Music]
uh i'm really very angry yeah because
i'm angry about the blackmail that the
government is doing
mostly for the young people but for
everybody but most for the young people
they are really blackmailing that
everybody has to go for the vaccine i
have had a vaccine myself
but i was very angry that my children
had had to have the vaccine and they
just took it because of the freedom yeah
they they want to travel they want to do
a sports competition
and they can't do it without a vaccine
but they didn't want to but it's just
blackmailed
you